yeah okay I hope I'm life had some
technical issues so i hope i'm actually
live now one little thing here and yeah
please let me know if I'm indeed live I
had some software hiccups here so I I
got that message that I'm not that's
cool okay so let's get going yeah
welcome back guys I'm back after about
five weeks I think five weeks of break
been been a while okay cool let's get a
game going and going to request I get a
oh I got a very high rated opponent yet
agua desire yeah I know that on on the
forums like on reddit there was a huge
discussion who that is he's very high
rated yeah 26 something um yeah someone
says looks like I've gotten some Sun
indeed I did I have not been to a
typical yeah holiday country but all
over Europe it was very very hot so I
got I got some exposure to the Sun
definitely okay so um yeah good old nims
oh my book repertoire mmhmm yeah I could
I could looks that look it up in my book
but I definitely won't that is a lot
like cheating so let's not do that okay
I'm trying to attack a center him i'm
not sure if i'm right with what i'm
doing here it's not totally according to
what i recommend i believe but anyway
let's get going yeah white has no
development here yeah i think it is
actually my book
one I think it is actually the case do I
go at five you're safe I think c4 and
then f5 but hmm there there's a game
there is a game Micky Adams with black
words like some the fear which I have
forgotten very reliably forgotten um
possibly five okay let's play that move
so um so there's a couple of questions
in the chat but I really want to see
what I can do against this player is
very strong so um how do I play that I
can take c3 and Bishop e7 or something
like that or Bishop if I don't know do I
want to play Bishop could be seven I can
take on these six antes got e6 very
sharp position I can also just take here
what happens if I just grab stuff let's
let's be greedy take on c3 check on d5
is that so bad let's let's let's check
probably not the best possible way to
play but i don't know i have to play
something he doesn't have um something
in his finger notes no no Wow to 680 is
really high okay so i was thinkin Queen
d5 here right just grab that pawn but
why definitely has some player on the
dark square so it's not that i'm just a
pawn up they're definitely not and I
have my doubts probably there's some
drawback to that
hmm yeah Bishop e3 and that that was
what I also was thinking myself tricky
am my rook is hanging and this godless
he's got Bishop d6 and some positions
okay let's start with this now I
expected that one but I couldn't really
do anything about it that's one problem
now I have to have to check i can go
okay i can go nite to a 6 I can defend
that oh not sure if it's a good idea
though hmm yes very nice compensation
Air Force pond how do i play this f5
porn is also week
I do this hmm i know i'm giving away a
five and can take be five and then it's
not good right okay i can take with the
korea it's got Bishop f4 hmm ok hmm yeah
this this so this is i'm giving away f5
which is not really great hmm can just
take at five I mean if maybe it's got
something better but Bishop takes at
five is just good for white ok that one
huh yeah it's not exactly bad either
threatening light chicks be five I would
like to play look check see 5 or
something I would g 6 9 p-5 going back
to g7 maybe that's why I took him that's
very true key
and I can take at five but maybe it's
got something better even that's
actually likely but jammed it is it is
just a good move what can you what can
you do yeah and queen g4s is in the mix
ok I'm going to trade Queens simply to
make sure that i'm not getting
checkmated quickly um yeah and my pieces
are not coordinated at all night seven
is also coming now that's not going to
work I cannot move both my nights which
is not a good sign not a good sign at
all
96 mm-hmm amongst others okay good I
mean this is not really helping God be
too I may I played that very nicely yeah
this this line is very sharp if you
forget your your stuff in blitz
difficult very difficult yeah that's a
line given in the chat but I don't think
that this this would have helped me that
much to be honest Queen B 6 check or not
I mean probably doesn't it wouldn't have
helped much yeah so let's do this and
now what I can take here I have
absolutely no move here that's a really
great I cannot move both nights which is
really not a good sign but let's see how
he converts this just night a 7 that's
certainly good enough but that's
probably better moves well night 87 it's
just good it's nothing nothing to
criticize about it yeah now I can't
resign that daddy played that very
nicely very nicely okay so let's go for
a new game and hope I mean this is cool
to have those kind of super high rated
guys but it's it's um yeah it's
difficult can we see in Evans gambit
yeah I can go for one if point hope that
that we get
okay so um there's a question if I think
that this opponent in the first guy was
a professional yeah if you got to 680 on
the five-minute pool um this is a very
strong GM normally it's very very
unlikely to be I mean the only question
is this year like top 50 guy or
something like that or it could be a
very strong blitz specialist but
definitely someone like clearly higher
than 2,500 okay so um we get an Spanish
exchange that's not very exciting I will
play some more enterprising openings a
bit later but ok I this guy allowed f5
which is good good news I get some good
pressure here on the e4 pawn early it's
not very often happening in the in the
Rue La Paz exchange maybe I even windows
e4 pawn yeah ok some more information
may be above my my break yeah if you are
interested I am own had some some good
time in my usual destination of Slovenia
I'm i go there basically every year in
the summer to to relax was very nice
again i also played some chess i played
a tournament in in poland in rod Slav
very very nice city very much to be
recommended if you intend to visit
Poland it's a very nice place to stay
the tournament in itself was some kind
of yeah mediocre result um on the other
hand I was still pretty okay with what I
did considering how hot it was I mean it
was basically impossible to sleep um
okay i will i set a little trap but
Knight f6 was clearly a not what he
wanted to do okay just a Texas
on her yeah definitely possible gym i
can't go Bishop c5 but he's got f3 hmm
yeah that's not so great but what can I
do let's cover five and the problem with
it that the heat during that tournament
wasn't so much the tournament itself I
mean the venue anything the problem was
that it was simply impossible to get our
apartment cool down yeah um it was such
as it was so hot that like for the whole
tournament and never slept more than two
or three hours at night and it was by
the end of it I was just like falling
asleep all of the tacky area was a bit
tricky but um what's in a nice
experience so it's very rare I mean I
will definitely consider to visit Poland
again and also the the city of Roger
loves very very nice place okay so I'm
trying to to do something here with my
with my bishops um where am I going to
put them my kinky walk maybe here
preventing night age five and Bishop g6
coming you at the end I got third place
in that event which is considering the
circumstances pretty okay um so I'm okay
I mean I lost like one or two rating
points I think um yeah well considering
that it felt like zombie all the time
that was okay but the question have you
ever been to Madrid no and four
did not I've only been in Bilbao last
year if it is for mainland Spain and on
my yoga two times yeah someone suggested
that I should play then the night off
memorial in Warsaw on us next year yeah
definitely why not it's an interesting
interesting idea have to check on about
next year how things some will be a hard
to tell right now but it's definitely an
interesting idea ok I'm going to try to
push him away with H form this is always
tricky to play with the bishop aru you
like your bishops but sometimes you have
to be feeling quite circumspect with
your maneuvers because if you push the
pawns in the wrong way it might easily
end up being yeah a situation where the
night's get good outpost it's not so
easy to play ok yeah he wants to go to
f3 it seems ha ok yeah h fri player
played this part 2 age form hmm ok maybe
that wasn't the greatest idea ever ok i
don't think i don't think i have a huge
problem yeah but it's kind of kind of
tricky am Knight to f3 is bit annoying
okay maybe start with that and go from
there Knight f3 mmmm yeah on Knight
takes h4 I would always be able to take
e to end F forward it's not totally
satisfactory probably I shouldn't have
pushed the edge porn but hindsight is
always twenty-twenty okay let's keep
that pawn someone suggests that I should
play the black side of the prologue AFC
variation of the night off I'm not
thinking that's such a great idea why do
title players have such an affection for
bishops even in positions where bishops
are bad they can't resist picking up the
bishop pair um well in this career in
this game it was just the opening line
that gave me the bishop pair but yeah
bishops arm are the better piece in in
many cases so title players 12 want the
bishops what Celia has simply overlooked
at that e 7 is hanging ok I thought you
would take with with the bishop
everything night I'm sorry talking about
bishops I'm even confusing the pieces
here ok but that isn't that terrible i
think the f5 part is not that weak can
get this play here or i can take this
pawn now and i will definitely take the
pawn so what is this idea now I mean the
e 2 nite is not doing much that will
definitely push be 5 and so on now what
is he going to do maybe 95 or 96
he's taking lots of time yeah someone
whites rights here it's usually easier
to open a position then to keep it
closed yes that's 11.11 thing about
bishops and nights and the other thing
is that is that once a position is open
it really closes down this is actually
the more important thing so quite often
you have a closed position but you can
open it up but vice versa is totally
yeah impossible once it's open there are
no points to close it down so there is a
certain inherent tendency of positions
to open up far more than to get to have
them have them closed down so I think
this is one one point where why bishops
often tend to be the better piece okay
um yeah I went for this because after be
takes okay now I get a pawn after beat
eggs I would have gotten a nice
dominating bishop against night can can
take the end go to e1 counter checking
the night but he's got a very active
rook now and that's it that's bad that's
bad okay but I don't want one to draw so
I'm going to to do it like that do I go
b5 here or not I can check him actually
that's a funny movie I cannot take the
pawn okay I came sorry that what I was
silly have a silly move
let's push stuff I've got two pawns but
how do I proven rook c8 I guess I don't
oops oops that was silly that was very
silly ah help help what a silly game
what did i do in this end game it was a
completely good rugged game oh my yeah
I'm rusty there was over a silly game ah
so um yeah someone writes if my book is
already released yes it is yeah i mean i
have a half one i have one here um yeah
it is not what can be ordered from from
shops um not sure if amazon already has
got it and i think it will take some
time probably um if you are very much
interested in in in a signed copy i send
out some so if you are you should
contact me on my my mail address which
is christophe zolecki first name last
name at gmail com so I'm going to play a
anum so here in this in this case I
wanted to go if all right but if you are
kind of rusty of you you tend to go back
to to basics or what you're watching no
best let's say which is default kind of
stuff ok I got an interesting position
here in which I'm actually giving up the
bishop pair but in return I've gotten
nice central control so I don't mind it
in this particular case huh interesting
where's he going he wants to go to d5
here
hmm f5 is an interesting move in this
position I want to try that it's an
interesting move takes rook e1 check yes
to move the King not quite sure how good
that is but it is an interesting move
let's do it okay check there's a
question do I have any in line suggests
for black playing into the French
advance um nothing in particular I mean
the French advances normally considered
to be quite okay for black it's not the
most critical line you can just play
main line with Bishop d7 105 or queen b
6i think they both should should be
totally okay so one if you are worried
about the French advance you're probably
playing the wrong opening it's one of
the lesser critical lines are thinking
the French okay here after d5 my ideas
to go Queen to d4 and ask him how it's
going to yeah sort of organize his his
position here he might have Queen to
have six okay not now not now because of
rook takes the aid 97 I can also take
yet so rook takes the eight is a pretty
big threat I was expecting Bishop d7 and
said there's a remark that 3b6 is
interesting in the advanced french i
don't like that move it's too passive
it's really a bit passive yeah okay this
one but now I have rookie one which
cannot be bad just threatening route
checks the aid this looks difficult to
play this position
for black but what exactly am I going to
play is rook e7 good on I mean I also
have d6d 6 also looks like a g6 shake
screen shakes and then rookie 7 at the
end hmm Claire looks pretty bad let's
play it not spend more time Krupa who is
that actually Charlie cop okay
yeah I g6 just opening up this bishop
I'm also threatening Bishop takes f7 now
so I think he he has to take on the six
anything else any other move would
surprise me greatly but if he takes um
well it's also bad can you do it's just
a bad position I think yeah to complete
my my story what I did in the in the
meantime yeah I played that tournament
and I also had some more travels um I
was also visiting some some some more
places i was visiting dresden yeah very
nice very nice city never been been
there and also i paid a very short visit
to a city off gurlitt's this is some the
the east the most eastern city of
germany it's a right at the the Polish
border it's also nice to nice to visit
so if you are here in Germany or and
that kind of area it's nice and I some
destinations to visit yeah so he asked
who has to go to h 2 h 6 which doesn't
look good but what what can he do and
not much alternatives okay um what to do
here it looks terrible but how do I win
this is the question I can just play
Bishop f7 which is probably not a bad
move intending Bishop takes g6 that's
probably go down let's play that
also queen air for gains in strength as
Queen GC as king g7 then can be answered
by the discovery about my my book I will
very shortly post a video on my channel
I mean very shortly means tomorrow
basically to to to show the contents and
ideas and stuff like that so um if you
are interested in learning what exactly
I'm i'm recommending in it it's it's
totally okay if you of you yeah it's
just wait till tomorrow that's what I'm
trying to say and you get a good
overview there's already something on
the publisher's website of course but
it's um maybe a video is more accessible
okay so i can give this check on f4 and
it's got g5 um and then how do I win I
don't see it the one with how I win he's
attacking my rope here so can also check
him on III and Jen g5 still this is a
bit of a bit of an annoying annoying we
reply here Queen a form petilla g5 this
this looks kind of terrible this g5 move
but no he's just retweeting i didn't i
didn't think about that movie that's a
very simple reply but now i can check
him here and check d 70 so i'm winning a
piece yeah dad was it wasn't that wasn't
a playable position white was just just
too too too much too much of an
advantage yeah i wasn't i wasn't sure if
i'm winning after g5 or how exactly i'm
winning after g5 it looks so very nice
but anyway okay my is a question will my
book be published as an e-book yeah it
will be
but that that takes take some time it's
a matter of the publisher so I cannot
really tell you how long it is some it's
going to take okay I tried something
offbeat but it's only going to be a
[ __ ] in nothing super crazy night at
396 but he played in this style of the
London system not doing anything
exciting so yeah so what is this yeah
probably have to take yeah someone is
responding to my statement that be 6 in
the advanced french is not such a great
line and he says that in the villanova
v6 is supposed to be okay yeah I mean
there's simply a different line in the
winner of them there's a knight on c3
and this is the most important thing in
the advanced french there's a poll on c3
all the time and b6 is just very slow in
this kind of this kind of setup okay um
can I go 5 vo I said too shaky a
probably Queenie for us coming yeah
maybe I can harass them a little bit
efore Bishop g4 is weakening the default
square okay I can also return now to 2h7
or something like that okay the chicken
is not exactly one of the lines that I
it that I do play so it's it's kind of
kind of tricky and this is this position
okay so what is he going to do probably
am playing for blowing playfully 5 or
what is he doing hmm
I mean at the moment 'if I've okay some
moving the King even in that diagonal
that's kind of surprising hmm how crazy
is f5 probably very crazy d5 that's 95
hmm ok so please playing very quick
routine moves that probably aren't the
best but still don't spoil much so if
I've here or not yeah I think I have to
do something in the center d 594 should
be ok yeah this was possible but still I
don't see if don't see that as being so
dangerous I can always claim that i have
two bishops which definitely is true but
it's not quite clear how important that
is hmm yeah he can definitely claim that
he's played it very quickly so what
happens here 'if I've I can take d 5
then Bishop h7 is happening mmm ok
that's not good online c7 is hanging and
it sets a problem
well okay what do I play here chinks
okay i can i can actually do this and
play Bishop b5 here right f takes rupee
Faruk d5 so the whole thing doesn't seem
to work but I've been very slow yeah the
d5 note is attacked and I don't see what
he's doing about it if we cover sit I'm
just dropping back to the 6 and I just
have one d5 pawn so we played quickly
but not very successfully ultimately
okay so let's just keep that pawn and go
from there yeah look 28 voice going for
rookie seven maybe mmm yeah I can I go I
can always give that check so like
rookie 7 Queen f5 check as possible on
our checking checking here it's not that
great so let's let's check in on that
square let's do some kind of a Quincy
for might happen not sure what's the
best move to make me to give me some
room for my king maybe c6
yeah that's a question um first they say
welcome back yeah I'm glad to be back
had a good time but doing my regular
things is also also cool so what am I
doing here and they say the question is
if I manage to see they see the game of
the year which is why he vs LA versus
bruise on yeah I saw that game it was
unavoidable basically and of course a
very nice game but I don't share them
some opinions that this is kind of the
game of the century or anything I just
found it pretty I don't know sorry I
just found it pretty normal game of
course it's AI mean I would be super
proud to have that kind of game played
yeah that's not the point but I think
that many many good grandmasters would
take on f7 just it's the most obvious
move in the position and you easily see
that it is a draw and from there you can
can work it out so I'm not really i mean
it's it's a great game but it's not it's
not comparable to too many games that
have have yeah have this kind of thing
attached like let's say Kasparov with
white versus to parlor of that game that
was much more aesthetic game for example
um ok anyway um we have this rook
endgame where I'm a pawn up but two
minutes down and yeah it's of course a
draw but this guy might play on time I'm
not sure you never offered to draw him
you have to push stuff it is of course
just a draw
yeah threatening meet with before which
is not going to happen
now he has to give that check now I can
offer it raw here no he prefers to
continue to play on time that's a
typical idiotic behavior online rather
giving up another pawn trying to win on
time in a game where he's got never got
anything
well maybe manages to lose this and in
the end yep so position will be will be
completely winning i blended that bloody
porn no rabbit is not taking it yeah I
lost some time this is why not increment
blitzes sometimes purely idiotic okay
anyway let's play another game so I
really hated um yeah the cool thing is
that I mean they just avoid the drawers
to win on time and making a total idiot
of themselves but okay we now know that
this guy well anyway let's play play a
new game and hopefully we get some I
cannot play three plus one because I CC
does not have an increment pool but i'm
not going to start that discussion now
because it's as old as i know very old
ok so we have haga here this guy is
playing b3 all of the time and again we
get it here we should be 5 56 and i keep
forgetting the theory how does this he
goes night a three and then I'm out of I
think no it takes interesting hmm that's
ended surprising actually okay let's
let's gain some space and hope that my
active pieces can do something good okay
so um he's got a nice center but I like
my bishops here of course that's a nice
position
well he couldn't Castle couldn't Castle
short um yeah so what we do i wonder if
i should play with f5 yeah making making
an ad for three plus one I don't know
what I mean nobody plays the challenge
system and I really don't see the point
it takes ages to get a good game the
pools are just much inferior a much
superior in comparison so it's just a
matter of having a good good pool
solution anyway let's let's look at that
game it's interesting hmm I wonder to
see half no no this is just a nice
position for black right what what is
why it's point in this game okay we'll
pray queen f3 maybe I think I should I
should try to activate everything here
f5 looks like a decent solution just
opening the position up Queen h4 was an
alternative trying to sacrifice on age 3
but Queen H Queen f3 look like a
defenses this is good I think activating
the rook right from the initial Square
and I'm threatening to take afore and
then queen edge for
and that looks like a good position I
was surprised how quickly like he took
very quickly on c6 that was very
surprising to me a rookie one
interesting he wants to check with the
rook that's interesting i DM on the
other hand um the rook is neglecting
ever tool he might have pawn to e5 that
that could be an idea ok I think I
should just take here and then Queen g5
okay it's taking with the night that
move I didn't expect at all after Queen
age flow i think i'm just in very good
shape I thought you would take with the
rook I thought that was the idea now I'm
threatening bishop age three and this is
this is kind of dangerous g3 queen age
three I cannot believe at all okay so if
I'm smashing now on age three what what
is this what is the defense hmm oh is
that maybe that is not that clear ok now
it's not that k SF 3 which continues
Bishop a tree looks like it should win
it really does maybe it isn't maybe it
isn't
chicks chicks f3 when I cannot swing the
rook over that sets really a that's
really a shame this this I don't see
when I don't see a win with Bishop h3
that's kind of crazy can i play some
other how do I prepare that I can play
maybe this one it's not all that what I
wanted to do but Bishop a tree didn't
seem to didn't seem to work yeah g3s
looking T gauge three I think should be
okay not totally clear but you have to
gamble a little bit
it's not quite clear what I'm
threatening actually the idea now is
root lee 6 g 6 in this position this is
why i wanted Bishop f5 simply to connect
rooks also Bishop h3 is getting a little
bit more interesting now as I am ok so i
can take here i still can take age 3 I
think takes takes takes threatening
Brooke g4 at the end see how is the
defending that I don't see it let's
let's see maybe I'm overlooking stuff
but let's just I Scott in high def 6
check when we were looking very simple
stuff takes Queen takes Bishop f4 rook
f4 is called Knight f6 check that's
quite simple to see but maybe okay it
takes I can actually take I can maybe
take no that's not as good
nice taking their even yeah you were
right I told I totally did not see that
Knight f6 is so strong very very silly
ah shoot what am i doing now
I have no decent move I has simply have
no move this is not really what you want
I'm just a piece down now very silly
yeah I simply overlooked like f6 check
at stuff
very bad
this time threatening Rugare to now okay
yeah I should simply I should lose now
of course but maybe he's doing something
stupid seems unlikely though it's very
that's very easy very easy stuff okay
and I can take their butt okay that's
the straight stuff can only hope on some
bad technical play but seems very
unlikely again okay yeah I'm down on
time as well maybe I should just resign
but the photo do I have to pause right
two pawns okay it's still not super
trivial to win this position is not
super coordinated really isn't night and
ruka not in good coordination I might
have rook drug to be three or something
I 9h six check mmm ok ok I'm going to
resign I don't want to do something me
again I'm even down long time yeah that
was a bad bad game a very bad decision
here to take on history I just I wasn't
simply seeing that he ate was hanging
here in this in this line and this makes
the whole thing bad i mean the position
was excellent for black but I simply
cannot sacrifice that I have to play a
conservative move move someone mentioned
take on e4 yeah I'm not winning back the
piece that line wasn't working rook
takes before and simply wasn't working
ok so I'm trying with one year for ok
let's get a king's gambit in I always
get requests for that for that silly
opening so why not ok someone playing
the the [ __ ] via counter gambit file
bear counter gambit I don't think this
is that great but I don't know what the
best line is I think this one but I
might be mistaken might be mistaken him
it's not a particularly popular line
anymore interesting I can take c6 being
greedy hmm said a good idea Black is got
very good development but I don't know I
really don't know what what the right
line is so let's just see that I get
some things developed here
someone asked he doesn't seem to be
extraordinary good you see top 500 and
what do you mean me um I'm not at the
top 500 my world rank something like I
know 1800 or something which is not that
bad considering that there's a couple of
million chess players around but there
are definitely better player so
obviously but I'm not that bad in blitz
chess it doesn't show at the moment I'm
totally honest them I'm very rusty after
that break I really have played for
about six weeks I didn't play a single
game of online chess and I only like
yesterday recorded a couple of blitz
games for my channel but I'm really
rusty it it's kind of obvious it's
better mean I'm not a great calculator
of tactics anyway and this break really
in some cases leads to situations where
I have huge problems to calculate so
what's here 95-94 something I it's got a
nice nice bishop pair quite quite
clearly g3 let's go g3
yeah it's got this that the bishops are
very strong there's someone asked about
my my bullet play yeah I'm not that bad
in it if I'm if I'm investing some time
to practice yeah I'm not great if I'm
not practicing but if I play a bit of
bullet and not not hopeless I have a
good basic speed and I see stuff but
it's it's not something that I do
regularly I don't play bulletins and
regular basis okay so um I have traded a
bit and I'm pretty happy that i get this
position I know it isn't isn't a great
or anything but i think i was under
pressure and this is definitely okay so
yeah it's difficult and i think i have
to change i have to trade and the bishop
is a bit stronger here then then the
night as it is usually but it's not
prolly not terribly bad here my king d 5
teeny three outside somewhere that's not
a good end game
it's not a particularly good end game
yep but not much else that I can do so
probably taking it so that I have
something that I can attack but how to
do it he can check me here you can go
with a night over to g3 and that's the
way maybe that's the way to do it um
currently I'm controlling that maybe
yeah okay mmm okay i came to nitey to
first is that somewhat better i know i
mean it's it's playable I think mmm Oh
interesting it's going to be five I can
go 94 now to rate this yeah it should be
okay it should be okay getting the f5
porn for sure ok take him yeah I'm not
much happening i think i'm going to
offer ok already offered me some drawers
yeah i have a sound off here so it ok so
i'm going to play one more game that was
a bit boring for the Kings gambit ok
there's a question um do do you ever
play
yeah that's great if I ever played efore
before I'm switched to d4 Knight f3 um I
have played a bit of before but not
really as my main move um I was always
more drawn to d4 kind of kind of
openings I have some experience before
but not really what you would call me
being an e4 player at 11 point of my my
chest Korea if you want a card like that
um and that's why do you think it's
essential for a good player to have
played d44 it's not essential but it's
not certainly not bad to have a wide
range of of lines that you have
experience and simply to know more kind
of position types that is definitely
useful okay this guy is trying to play
an offbeat response to my off beat be
three okay let's see what happens if
both players try to play strange stuff
it seems like we get some some type of
Sicilian oh okay interesting I'm going
to try to be active here and try to
Castle long maybe I know d3 is that
occur where it looks like a bit of a
strange move here let's see what to do
Queen f3 or something yeah knight c6
looks like a problematic move then now
it looks a bit strange here this um this
thing the combination of b3 and d3 and
so on that's probably one of those don't
try this at home openings but anyway it
will see what happens in mind is that
move evening
interesting okay
I wonder if he has some kind of tactic
with queer now okay but this isn't that
bad huh is that the set of bad position
I mean I'm pretty active here with Queen
age five and I can castle long I'm not
sure that this was such a great idea for
him it looked fancy but I don't know if
this was really good
yeah that's all sometimes the problem
and this G takes f6 kind of structures
that you allow a queen coming to age 5
which is really annoying here and he's
not so easily preparing long castling
yeah that moves but I can Castle long
right k can take f3 it's not not that
great difficult okay he can maybe take
their on f3 and play Queen d5 returning
a pawn on a returning upon is wrong but
giving away possibly f6 form for
activation that might be might be an
idea yeah that was a good resource
knight c6 night to deform what is he
going to do
No
someone recommends one Knight c3 as a
first move yeah it's not that bad why
should this move be particularly bad
develops a piece I don't think that you
can really seriously play for an opening
advantage but it's certainly not a not a
bad move 193 ok so I'm going to try this
for Bishop b5 this is a big threat now
there should be five king of a teenager
6 and checkmate and I'm threatening also
to take on c5 opening up the stuff here
I'm not sure what is reply is now that
that looks dangerous for black
that looks very tricky yes someone since
93 doesn't give me an opening advantage
but my goal is to just get to an equal
chances middle game yeah sure I mean I'm
not criticizing your idea it really is
an okay idea to play to play 193 okay um
speaking of what is this I can play this
is quite nice i can go d 5 or can check
him I wonder what what is better d 5s
maybe better
okay let's start with d5 Bishop takes
Bishop b5 check is winning straight away
so probably pawn takes is what he has to
do Bishop b5 check Bishop c655 as a line
someone says you want to equalize as
Wyatt you're doing it wrong I actually
once thought about writing a book with
the title equalized with white and be
happy it's not a bad this is a funny
title but I think there's some some
truth to it against good play you can
only equalize anyway and with white I
mean so why not just be happy about it
and play just go for something that you
like and don't worry so much about
hunting for an opening advantage that
probably is not there anyway okay um
anyway here in fact I should have
something the question is how exactly
should I play that looks very nice but
he's attacking cfia was check so
something to be aware of okay maybe
start with that it was a tempo so it
cannot cannot be that bad rookie one is
a kind of normal looking let's do that
maybe there's something better but it's
not a bad news
Jim I'm not threatening something
directly here that's the the downside of
that I don't have a direct threat Queen
f5 threatening Bishop f6 soever is a
threat what is he doing against it Group
the eighth
so can play Bishop f6 rook takes seven
is pretty pretty big threat so let's
check there's something better than
rookie five is there mate I don't see it
at the moment but Luke g7 has a double
check
that's it sits nice um are you resigned
yeah it's a it's pretty nice em it's
going to be checkmate oh I can win
basically all pieces um yeah the guy um
who and who suggested 193 yeah it's not
a bad a bad line I mean a good replies
actually one Knight f6 to 193 okay so um
okay i hope you enjoyed the stream it
yeah it showed that I'm a bit rusty from
my blood from a break but I hope it will
improve until next week so um yeah I
hope it was yeah you had a good time
that's a question if I was born and
raised in Russia where we're in the top
10 would you rank YY in the top 10 no
definitely not yeah I mean you can
always play better than then you I mean
if you focus more on playing but it's
not a not such a huge difference where
you were born or anything it's a matter
of of effort invested and then what you
what kind of talent you haven't it's
some not very much dependent on one
where you are located okay hope you
enjoyed it I'm going to be back next
week thanks guys bye